en chine aujourd'hui le gouvernement a
reconnu la très grande gravité de la
situation le premier ministre et le chef
du parti communiste chinois ont tenté
d'établir un dialogue avec les étudiants
mais la foule continue de grossir elle
exige la démocratie plus d'un million de
gens aujourd'hui dans les rues de pékin
georges porteuse de très bonne heure 1 5
heures du matin les principaux
dirigeants chinois dont le secrétaire
général du parti et le premier ministre
ont rendu visite dans un hôpital de
pékin à plusieurs grévistes de la faim
hospitalisé c'était un geste du pouvoir
mais la grève de la faim continuaient
pourtant ici juste devant le siège du
gouvernement et du parti un jeune homme
avait inscrit sur le bandeau lui fermant
la bouche
pas d'eau pas dont la grève la plus dure
et la plus dangereuse
toute la journée aussi à continuer le
défoulement populaire toute la journée
on a scandaient des slogans souvent très
durs pour les dirigeantes du parti
tout le monde semble hélas les jeunes
les moins jeunes les nostalgiques de mao
il y avait même une délégation de
catholiques chinois manifestants pour la
liberté du culte un défoulement une
manifestation si énorme qu'on se demande
si elles étaient seulement tolérés
s'il n'y avait pas là une sorte de coup
politique que prépare certains la cible
désignée c'est dacia ping alors très
évidemment c'est un énorme spectacle est
d'abord un drame politique
premièrement comment va évoluer le
régime
et puis deuxième mort qui va prendre la
succession de taye